How does a filmmaker show an idea?
I believe in ancestry, you know and
and legacy. How things don't go away.
I want to show you a technique director Derek
Cianfrance uses to communicate abstract concepts
visually in The Place Beyond the Pines, an
underrated film from 2013 that I’m about
to completely spoil.
The Place Beyond the Pines is about the passing
of the torch, how our legacy effects our children
and those around us.
Our actions have consequences, and those consequences
echo out from us affecting those around us,
sometimes for generations.
And while this is something we understand
almost instinctually about real life, it can
be hard to convey that on screen.
You could edit a story non-linearly highlighting
the connections between actions and their
consequences, but Cianfrance decided to show
Pines linearly, in three distinctive acts.
So how do you show the relationship between
two events separated by minutes or hours of
film?
I think the themes in Pines are most strongly
communicated visually through Sean Bobbit’s
beautiful cinematography, and the staging
and locations of each scene.
How do you connect Luke Glanton, who’s only
alive in the first 50 minutes of the movie,
and his son who’s only on screen in the
last 50.
Like this.
In the director’s commentary Cianfrance
talks about how many of the scenes have echos
later in the film.
Visual motifs and recurring locations show
how you can feel connected to someone’s
legacy even after they’ve been dead for
15 years.
With shots like these we can connect a father
and son’s shared love of riding.
Their free spirits.
We can connect their crimes.
Show how they develop similar friendships.
These visual connections helps the audience
understand the relationship between these
two figures who are hardly ever on screen
together.
A scene towards the end of the film where
Jason visits the trailer is dad lived in 15
years earlier, visually echoes the scene where
Luke sees the trailer for the first time.
These two scenes, are an hour apart in the
film, but when they’re cut together you
can see how clearly they interact with each
other.
The feeling of connection that the characters
are feeling in that moment is palpable to
the viewer.
Our memory is triggered when we recognize
the look of the scene from before, and it
puts us emotionally in the shoes of the characters.
But Cianfrance doesn’t just use these echos
to connect father and son.
He uses it to compare and contrast.
Look at this scene where Jason eats ice cream
for the first time with his biological father,
alongside a later scene where he icecream
at the same place, with the man that raised
him.
The second scene could have happened anywhere,
but by placing it here, the spector of Jason’s
biological father looms over the entire moment,
and we immediately know that this statement,
“I’m your real dad”, doesn’t find
it’s mark.
The similarities between the scene where Luke
and Avery try to give money to Romina, help
drive home how the conflict that entered her
life will Luke continue past his death.
We can see, just through the visual subtext,
how this relationship has had an impact on
this one.
The scene where Bradley Cooper’s character
picks up Luke’s son from the crib after
his death, echoes an earlier scene where Luke
comforted his held his own son.
We can see how this child has had an impact
on these two men in similar ways.
Setting these two scene in a pool, reinforce
how where Avery had a strong connection with
his dad, he lacks one with his son.
Film is a powerful medium for storytelling
because it gives you some many options simultaneously
for how to communicate ideas.
Cianfrance uses these echos to almost get
inside your head at times, as the viewer we’re
affected, but we might not even understand
why.
I think the themes in pines are most strongly communicated visually
through Sean Bobbit's beautiful cinematography and the staging and locations of each scene.
I've only covered some of the echoes that are in the Place Beyond the Pines
I’ll leave you with a side by side comparison
of the first and last shots of the film.
The entire thrust of the story is summed up
in these shots.
The generational evolution is made clear.
Jason is similar to his father, it’s easy
to imagine him as a young Luke in this shot,
but where Luke rides into a cage, Jason rides
off into freedom,
to the place beyond the pines.